Benefits you can obtain as a Brazilian citizen?
Stay with me,
because you get the advantages of being a
citizen when you naturalize here in Brazil.
When you have your citizenship,
you can have certain benefits.
First of all,
you are going to have your Brazilian passport.
You can apply for your Brazilian passport,
a passport with which you will have free notice for European countries.
I don't know about you,
but I love to travel and having a passport that
opens the doors to 173 countries is a wonderful benefit.
Well, nothing,
the other thing,
uh,
you will be able to vote and be voted.
That means you will be able to participate,
vote in the elections here in Brazil.
You will have a readership and you will participate in your vote counts.
You will count your vote in the elections in
this country and you will also be able to be voted.
It means that you can hold political office if you wish.
Um,
did you hear that right?
Well yeah,
nothing,
yeah,
uh besides that,
you want to know what other benefit you have?
Know that you can participate in public competitions.
As a citizen,
you can hold certain public functions and positions,
whether in education or health.
Very good,
because,
uh,
here in certain municipalities,
states,
there are many public competitions.
Public competitions that are to occupy,
eh,
vague positions,
public functions.
And that is also a wonderful benefit.
Nothing.
The purpose of this video was to,
uh,
find out what the difference is between being a resident AND being a citizen.
What can change in your life if you naturalize here in Brazil?